Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Ist dir die Hitze gut überstanden?
Ja, denn ich habe ja zu Hause eine Klimaanlage.
Ja, das ist sehr vorteilhaft. Unsereiner, die armen Kirchenmäuse haben natürlich keine, sondern nur ein Dachgeschoss. Und ich habe die Tage im Freibad verbracht und es war zu warm. Ich weiß nicht genau, die Nachrichtenlage, ich hätte gedacht, es kommt ein bisschen mehr Stress auf, aber ich habe auch nicht mehr so den Zugang. Ich weiß, also ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, wo ich nachgucken müsste, um zu erfahren, was RTL aktuell oder ob es das überhaupt noch gibt und so.
Wie die jetzt noch darüber reden. Und auch das Regionalfernsehen hat schon relativ viel über die Hitze berichtet. Es sind ja Leute zusammengebrochen auf der Straße. Auch was das für wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen hat. Denn wenn man das mal durchrechnet, ist es nicht nur in Spanien, sondern auch in Deutschland natürlich inzwischen so, dass diese Hitze Einbußen beim BIP bedeutet.
In Spanien minus 1,4, habe ich gedacht.
Ja, man kann es also auch aus einer wirtschaftlichen Perspektive sich ansehen. Naja, und das ist schon sehr drastisch. Und ich war noch auf der Fülcolón. Und ja, da war dann der Saal klimatisiert. Das hilft. Aber irgendwann muss man mal raus oder rein und dann merkt man es schon, ne?
Ja, also ich habe mir vorgenommen, es sind ja jetzt so zehn Tage, bis es mal wieder über 30 ist. Ich werde jetzt mit KI-Hilfe, Hitzepläne. Also klar, man kann jetzt ausweichen in Orte, wo es Klimaanlage gibt und so. Aber Freibad, da gibt es noch so ein bisschen Optimierungspotenzial finde ich. Schon allein bei der Frage, wo stehe ich eigentlich mein Fahrrad hin? Wie finde ich raus, wo 15 Uhr der Schatten steht und so?
Das macht jetzt alles die KI bei dir bald.
Ja, also es gibt verschiedene Apps, zum Beispiel für Fotografie, wo du so Schattenverläufe schon mal voraussägen kannst für den ganzen Tag. Und so. Und die kann man ja alle umnutzen jetzt. Und lauter solche Spiele rein.
Das klingt wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ich hab manchmal den Eindruck, dass ich höre ja auch viele Podcasten, den Leute von ihren KI-Erfahren berichten. Und ich denke manchmal so, mach doch die Tür einfach mal mit der Hand auf.
Oder so.
Also das ist mitunter denke ich, ja, man kann natürlich 17 Apps da produzieren, um dies und das zu machen. Aber manchmal hilft ja auch zum Beispiel, ich hab keine Wetter-App. Ich gucke auch manchmal einfach aus dem Fenster raus und sehe, ah, es regnet.
Also Wetter-App ist auch noch so eine Sache, denn wenn die Ankündigung ist, 19 Uhr wird es kühler und bis 24 Uhr noch 30 Grad. Interessiert mich genau, was in diesen fünf Stunden passiert. Ich will da nicht einfach so eine drei Stunden Vorhersage haben, sondern aber gut, später dann.
Aber was machst du, wie richtest du dein Leben dann darauf aus?
Ja, ich will zum Beispiel wissen, ob mit Temperaturabfall Wind einhergeht und wann dazu erwarten ist.
Und dann weißt du, sonst kannst du nicht aufs Rad steigen? Oder was machst du davon abhängig?
Aufs Rad würde ich sowieso nicht steigen. Ich bin ja dann im Überlebensmodus. Aber ich würde dann schon mal so ein bisschen, es ist jetzt dunkel, ungewöhnliche Zeit, um rauszugehen. Aber vielleicht doch einfach mal rausgehen. Schon allein, weil draußen ein bisschen mehr Wind weht oder so. Lauter solche Sachen. Ich werde dich auf dem Laufenden halten.
Ja.
Es ist ja gerade mal angefangen Juli. Das ist ja wirklich verrückt.
Wir haben heute etwas vor. Wir sprechen heute über ein Buch eines Journalisten, der in allen Talkshows Dauergast ist. Der ist wahrscheinlich der bekannteste Politikjournalist zurzeit. Robin Alexander, er arbeitet für die Welt, hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Letzte Chance, der neue Kanzler und der Kampf um die Demokratie. Vorne auf dem Cover sind die Köpfe von Merz, Trump und Alice Weidel zu sehen. Wir sprechen gleich ausführlich über dieses Buch, aber wir müssen glaube ich schon mal davor einige Sätze sagen, denn wir haben ja hier sehr ausführlich im Podcast zum Beispiel die Berichterstattung reportiert zu den Attentaten, wie beispielsweise Reporter auf Weihnachtsmärkten herumstehen und sagen, ja, da waren Poller frei und da ist er da durchgekommen. Und es läuft noch das Sanitätspersonal links und rechts vorbei und man sendet aber einfach weiter und macht schon eine spannende Story draus. Wir haben gesehen, wie wir nur Emotionalisierung bekommen, auch von den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, dass man da überhaupt nicht runterbremst. Und jetzt wird eigentlich an diese Emotionalisierung angeknüpft und ich habe so viele Fragen an dieses Buch an dich, an den Politikstil, der damit einhergeht und vor allem auch an diese Art des Journalismus. Denn dieses Buch handelt natürlich implizit vom Journalismus, ohne das wirklich transparent zu machen. Denn wir sehen ja hier eigentlich den Journalismus als einen ganz wichtigen Akteur, der aber immer so unter den Teppich gekehrt wird. Ich finde, es ist ein ungeheuer aufschussreiches, grauenhaftes Buch.
Also ja, und es ist also alles, was du sagst, plus finde ich halt ein brutaler Eingriff in den Lauf der Dinge. Denn einfach nur zu sagen, der Journalismus wird da nicht mitreflektiert, ist ja das eine. Ich finde aber auch, es gibt verschiedene Strategien, wie Leute Sachbücher schreiben. Ich zum Beispiel sage mir gerade, ich schreibe gar nicht, weil diese KI-Welle soll jetzt erstmal über die Verlage hinwegrollen, wie auch immer. Also da verbrennen sich ja alle die Finger. Und da bin ich lieber Zaungast und stehe daneben und leide ein bisschen mit. Hier allerdings haben wir es mit einem Autor zu tun, der sich einfach denkt, das, was die KI am allerbesten kann, nämlich einen Deep Research anfertigen, etwas chronologisch zusammenzufassen, eine Rekombination aus 100 Zeitungstexten in einen roten Faden, das macht er. Mit dem wahrscheinlich erschlagenen Totschlagargument, dass der Subtext dieses Buches immer ist, man kann eigentlich das alles nur beurteilen, wenn man wirklich jedes Detail kennt. Und ich kenne jedes Detail. Ich habe ein Buch darüber geschrieben.
Und ich habe Zugang zu jeder Chatgruppe, jeder spielt eine Information zu. Das muss man vielleicht für die Leute sagen, die jetzt Robin Alexander nicht so kennen. Robin Alexander ist der, der immer informiert ist über alles. Er pflegt also sehr gute Kontakte zu offenbar allen Parteien, vor allem aber CDU, SPD und grüne FDP. Von ihnen bekommt er offenbar immer direkte Informationen zugespielt. Auch alle Dinge, die sonst nicht an die Öffentlichkeit so schnell gelangen, gelangen erst einmal zu Robin Alexander. Er ist quasi so ein Intermediär im politischen Feld geworden, der dort alle Informationen sammelt, deshalb immer sehr exklusiv sein kann. Dadurch natürlich ein Detailwissen hat, was sonst keiner haben kann.
Das würde ich mal abstreiten.
Beziehungsweise er hat bestimmte Details, die er gesteckt bekommt und andere bekommen andere Details gesteckt. Und man sieht auch in dem Buch, dass einmal jemand ja auch sehr viele Details plötzlich hat. Und das ist ihm gar nicht so recht. Das ist nämlich Robert Pausch von der Zeit, als es darum geht, dass die FDP dieses verrückte Paper da vorlegt. Dieses, was ist das, Doomsday und so weiter. Genau, D-Day. Wie sie da aussteigen wollen. Also wir werden darüber jetzt nachher noch ausführlich reden. Aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal, weil das immer so unser Thema war, über diese Emotionalisierung sprechen.
Ich will noch mal kurz bei dem Storytelling an sich bleiben. Also du hast hier ein Buch, das im Grunde von einem Autor kommt, der sagt, ich habe ja auch damals bei Hard Aber Fair im Nachhinein so angesprochen, wie du schon mit deinem Podcast zufrieden bist und er so, ja ich hätte gerne mehr Zeit und so. Dann fragt er, was hören Sie denn über Podcasts? Ich habe ja gar keine Zeit zum Podcast hören und so. Und wir kennen alle diesen Habitus, der dann so kommt mit so irgendwelche Podcasts, da schreiben wir so Bücher, 140 Seiten, was kann man da schon machen? Es müssen 450 sein. So diese 450 kommen aber ohne Tiefgang. Also es wird einfach nur, du hast jetzt diese Pausch-Sache angesprochen, also in der Zeit große Investigation, wie die FDP die Ampel zerstörte. Und da sieht man ja, also wo sozusagen publizistisches Gegenfeuer, wo er weiß, ne, das haben die Leute jetzt im Hinterkopf, da muss ich kurz explizit werden. Und dann findet so eine Relativierung statt. Ne, es hat doch jede Partei gemacht und die FDP hat sich nur besonders dumm angestellt und so. Also wir könnten sozusagen jetzt in Salon, das Buch ist 450 Seiten, also 4 Stunden 50 darüber reden, wie er das chronologisch gestaltet. Aber ich will jetzt gleich auf eine andere Ebene helfen, zumindest von meiner Seite, denn ich halte diese Strategie, dieses Merkelsche, meine Sitzung dauert am längsten. Mein Buch ist noch nicht zu Ende erzählt, da seid ihr schon alle müde. Aber ich hab's nicht nur geschrieben, ich hab's auch eingelesen, Wort für Wort und so, ja. Also diese Arbeitswut, die da drinsteckt, dieses Erschlagen, dieses Überrumpeln, das ist eine ganz fiese und sehr perfide Strategie. Und damit kommt man auch biografisch sehr viel weiter, weil das ist im Grunde, wir kennen das schon von Markus Feldenkirchen und so, diese Einladung. Lieber Wahlkämpfer, ich glaube, du wirst Erfolg haben, weil in Deutschland gibt es ja nur zwei Parteien, wer soll sonst Erfolg haben? Guck mal, ich habe schon zwei solche Bücher geschrieben, lass mich doch mal näher ran. Und dann bist du in so einem Stefan Lambi. Also ich mach natürlich den Film über die Chronik, wo nochmal die Tagesschau und zusammengefasst werden und so. Aber ich bin dann auch dabei, wenn sie in den Fahrstuhl steigen und lauter so. Und da kommt so ein Spin rum, aber ganz unscheinbar. Man sieht ihn kaum, aber er ist total wirkmächtig. Wo hier so die Normalitäten sind, wo die Gefahren lauern und so. Das wird dann einfach so eingebaut in den Text. Das müssen wir heute so ein bisschen rauskratzen. Und bevor du in deine Kritikrichtung gehst, würde ich hier gern ganz paradigmatisch, existenziell einmal gegen anargumentieren. Und in zwei Punkten. Das eine ist die Perfidie. Ich war bei Hart aber fair. Am 11.11.2024. Das war eine sehr aufgeregte Zeit, denn es waren gerade fünf Tage oder so und die Ampel war Geschichte. Vier. Und ich traf dort auf Robin Alexander. Ich habe versucht, dort Argumente zu machen. Schuldenbremse, Schuldenbremse, Schuldenbremse. Hat natürlich nicht ganz gefruchtet. Wir hören hier mal hinein in einen Clip. Es geht um eine folgende Auseinandersetzung. Du hast ja die Emotionalität eben schon angesprochen. Die wird natürlich gleich ein tragendes Ding spielen. Robin Alexander doziert so über diese Frage. Also der Scholz war ja ganz schön gut vorbereitet. Fünf Minuten nachdem er den Vizekanzler entlassen hat und hat plötzlich so ein Statement gehabt, das er Wort für Wort abgelesen hat, der war verdächtig gut vorbereitet auf so eine Situation, wo er uns doch vorgaukelte, aus der Emotion heraus das Land zu schützen und die Ampel zu kippen. Und dagegen argumentiere ich mal an. Und jetzt vergleichen wir mal seine Argumentation, die ihm so wichtig ist, dass er mir sogar ins Wort fällt mit dem, was er heute Morgen bei TableMedia gesagt hat. So im Grunde genau demselben Sachverhalt. Also hier Geschichtsstunde, harter Buffet aus dem Herbst.
Schulz hat es dann aber durchgesetzt, hat gesagt, er entlässt ihn jetzt. Hat der Kanzler da Führungsstärke gezeigt?
Kann man diskutieren. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob dieser Art Fokus auf diesen Human Interest, es sind immer gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten, wie auch immer. Und wir können auch nicht dem Kanzler unterstellen, professionell vorgegangen zu sein. Also ein Statement für eine Eventualität, von denen Herr Kubicki meint, das hat sich doch monatelang angebahnt, sagen alle, er hat da Text vorbereitet. Ja, er hat Text vorbereitet.
Ja, nur dann kann man nicht sagen, er war emotional. Also entweder hat er vorbereitet oder hat aus der Emotion agiert. Aber es kann nur eins stimmen.
Er hat ihn vorbereitet und dann aus der Emotion heraus vorgetragen. Der Fokus ist aber, der Text war vorbereitet, weil er Deutschland eine Aufgabe stellt. Es ging darum, Schaden vom Land abzuwenden. Und dieser Schaden wurde auch benannt, die Schuldenbremse. Ich weiß nicht genau, das ist jetzt fünf Tage her, wie diese Botschaft verloren gehen konnte, wie diese Frage nicht mehr gestellt werden kann. Stattdessen müssen wir jetzt, wie emotional war er denn? Ungewohnt emotional? Okay, war es wirklich sehr ungewohnt emotional? Nein, ich habe ihn im Hinterzimmer schon mal so und so erlebt. Das sind alles Fragen. Die haben überhaupt nichts in dieser Situation verloren.
Gar nichts.
Sehr gut.
So, Robin Alexander sagt also, man kann nicht beides sein. Der Schulz kann auf gar keinen Fall emotional sein.
Und vorbereitet.
Und gleichzeitig vorbereitet. Auf eine Eventualität, bei der alle seit Monaten schreiben, morgen ist es so weit. Na gut, übermorgen.
Also Leute, die zum Beispiel Grabreden halten, die sind darauf vorbereitet. Aber die können trotzdem in dem Moment emotional sein. Und das übermant einen manchmal selbst in Momenten, in denen man genau weiß, ja, lass dich gleich nicht übermannen. Das ist so ein eigenartiges Gefühl. Werd jetzt nicht zu sentimental in diesem Moment bei der Preisverleihung zum Beispiel oder sonst was. Und dann sehen wir, dass selbst Leute, die im Business immer die Profis sind, plötzlich sehr emotional werden. Und er will aber jetzt hier ja die ganze Zeit darüber reden, wie emotional er ist. Und du versuchst ein inhaltliches Argument zu bringen, die Schuldenbremse. Aber die spielt jetzt keine Rolle, weil wir ja von Emotionen getrieben sind. Aber man muss sagen, nee, er ist von Emotionen getrieben.
Und ich würde ja sogar so weit gehen zu sagen, und das ist dann Vorbereitung auch auf Clips gleich, aber auch so unsere Erfahrung jetzt mit Bühnrealität. Gerade die Vorbereitung ist vielleicht ein besonders gelingender Umgang. Und zwar auch aus Authentizitätsgründen mit Emotionen. Denn sich einfach nur krass, ich bin überwältigt von einer Emotion, ich hau mich weg, sondern nein, gerade wenn man es gestaltet, hat es ja sozusagen ausbreitenden, infizierenden Charakter auf eine Trauer gemeinte, noch mal, ah ja stimmt, das sind die Emotionen, um die es jetzt geht. Und dann gehört zur Trauer vielleicht auch Freude auf Erfahrung, wie auch immer, das kann man dann plötzlich alles so einbauen. So, wer mal es jetzt gehört? Nee, der Sachstand Schuldenbremse und so weiter, das muss hier ausgeblendet werden. Scholz war emotional und er hat uns aber belogen, weil er war vorbereitet. Jetzt hören wir denselben Sachverhalt, Schuldenbremse, aber eben nicht Scholz, sondern Merz, Sitzelenski im Oval Office, der ganze Kram, der hier so thematisiert wird. Und heute Morgen argumentiert Robin Alexander so im Gespräch mit Michael Brücker.
Und da sagen die Leute, wah, ein riesiger Wahlbetrug und so weiter. Man kann auch sagen, vorausschauende Politik. Ja, also ich meine, ich würde das so sagen, ist... Du bist da sehr sanft mit ihm in dieser Geschichte. Nein, ich bin nicht sanft, ich versuche präzise zu sein und den Menschen gerecht zu werden.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Also schau, ist Friedrich Merz im Innersten erschüttert dadurch, dass JD Vans in München sagt, das Problem sind nicht die Russen und die Chinesen, sondern euer Verhältnis zur Meinungsfreiheit. Er ist erschüttert. Ist Friedrich Merz erschüttert darüber, dass Zelensky so gedemütigt wurde im Overlaufen? Er ist erschüttert. Zweite Frage, nutzt er diese Erschütterung politisch und begründet etwas, was er tun muss? Ja, auch dies, beides kann parallel wahr sein.
Ach so.
Hört, hört.
Jetzt plötzlich doch.
Tja. Also das ist diese Perfidie, die da einfach sich 450 Seiten lang durchzieht. Und deswegen muss sie fundamental zu drüber werden.
Das ist sehr intelligent, dass man das nicht so leicht merkt. Man hat es hier mit einem intelligenten Autor zu tun, der sehr gut Dinge lancieren kann. Und da muss man aber erkennen, welche Absichten sind wieder hinter.
Ganz genau.
Und hier wird auch ein Heiligenbildchen gemalt für Friedrich Merz. Das werden wir nachher sehr ausführlich uns ansehen.
So, und deswegen wechseln wir kurz das Genre und gehen in die Las Vegas Zauber Show. Es geht um Penn Gillette, der ist dort sehr berühmt. Er hat seine eigene Show im Rio gehabt, ein unglaublich riesiges Hotel und so weiter mit großem Festsaal unten. Und er hat heute einen Podcast. Also er macht immer noch diese Penn und Teller Show mit seinem Kumpel, der aber auch einen Podcast. Und wir hören jetzt mal eine Minute 30, spontan. Und ich sage vorher, ist so ein bisschen knapp nebene Spur. Aber danach die zwei Clips, auf die kommt es mir an. Und die müssen von der, also die müssen sozusagen in diesem Gespräch kurz aufgehangen werden. Also hier Penn kriegt spontan eine Frage.
You seem less comfortable than I am with the fact that nothing I remember is accurate. Nothing any of us remember is accurate.
I bother you? So, also es geht hier um die Frage. Können wir uns eigentlich damit abfinden, dass alles, woran wir uns erinnern, gar nicht so korrekt ist? Also wenn ich jetzt 450 Seiten Buch schreibe, eine Erinnerung darlege, was hat es mit der eigentlich auf sich? Und er versucht jetzt erst mal spontan so zu antworten. Die zwei Clips gleich kommen über eine Stunde später in diesem Gespräch. Da ist er dann sozusagen bei Fassung.
We, we, we don't, nothing we remember is accurate. Because there is no story. Nothing is really happening out in the world. Everything is models inside our head.
Right, and so are you uncomfortable with that or are you comfortable with it? Because when I found it, as I learned about that, I became more comfortable because once I understood humans as narrative seeking individuals that were constantly, you know, the split brain experiments from the 1970s, they induce people to take an action and it's happening. Like, like for example.
Yeah, but cut to the chase. There's no free will and there's no world out there. Now what do you want to argue about?
Well, I guess, like I, you've talked before about how you check your diary in the past and. I do.
Because I like, part, okay, let's put this in terms you can understand. You're communist, you're communist. Part of my false narrative is to try to correct other false narratives.
That work?
So, er hat also eine Frage gestellt, an der er erstmal scheitert. Ja, also, es gibt keine richtige Realität, alles passiert nur im Kopf, aber wir können die ja trotzdem verarbeiten, um wissentlich falsche, aber vielleicht mit dem Willen es doch irgendwie richtig zu machen, andere zu überzeugen davon, dass sie es ein bisschen falscher gemacht haben oder wir irgendwie so, ja. So, und jetzt eine Stunde später in dem Gespräch kommt er zurück zu dieser Frage und möchte sie jetzt beantworten. Und er macht wirklich, also das ist, das sind so kleine Clips für die Ewigkeit, ja. Hier erster Aufschlag.
Where's when I'm writing fiction?
So, es geht um die Frage, und er hat nicht nur Zauber-Shows gemacht in Las Vegas, sondern auch Bücher geschrieben. Und er schwenkt gerade oben von Journalismus hier, da die Wahrheit auf Fiction. Welchen Mehrwert hat eigentlich mal Roman, Beledrissig am Schreibtisch zu sitzen und nicht die ganze Zeit so kronistenpflichtig rumzureihen?
Where's when I'm writing fiction, it's remarkable because in my latest book, you know, Bellamy Juggler, I detail all the stories that I believe truly happened to me. And the weird thing is, because it's fiction, I believe I can be more accurate to the story that's in my mind. So what you want to do, I think, is you want to have a story in your mind that you know is not true. And in order to make someone else share the world with you, you want to have enough points that agree with their narrative, that there can be sharing. And the only way to have that sharing is to agree that there is some sort of world out there, that we can find out things about and share.
Ja, also, ja, Realität schön und gut und irgendwelche Journalisten, die auf irgendwelchen Republikakonferenzen sitzen, um irgendwann nochmal in Objektivität und so weiter. Wir hatten ja auch kürzlich in Hamburg eine Kontroverse zu dieser Frage, wo das Publikum auch so ein bisschen, was sagt der Herr Schulz da und so. Genau, was ist mit der Wahrheit und so? Nein, es geht hier nicht um Realität und Wahrheit. Es geht um Resonanz und Widerstände.
Ja, beziehungsweise um Erinnerung, Konstruktion, Erzählung, Ereignis.
Genau.
Also es gibt Ereignisse und die sind wahr. Wie sie aber dann zu Erzählungen werden, beziehungsweise in der Erinnerung zu Erzählungen werden, ist das was anderes. Und wir haben ja hier Ereignisse, so suggeriert uns Robin Alexander, die zu einer Politik führen, dass aber da eine Erzählung draus gemacht wird aus den Ereignissen. Und aus der Erzählung wird eine Politik dann gemacht. Das wird hier nicht reflektiert. Und ich werde ja heute noch ein Buch vorstellen, eine Poetik-Vorlesung von Barbie Markovic. Und diese Schriftstellerin spielt sehr mit der Frage Wahrheit und was darf man sich aneignen, was nicht, was ist mit der Realität. Und sie zitiert Proust und sie macht aber dann gleich eine Fußnote Proust aus dem Gedächtnis zitiert. Also wir wissen gar nicht, ob das wirklich ein Proust-Satz ist. Und Proust soll gesagt haben laut Barbie Markovic, Unsere Wahrheit verändert sich für uns so sehr, dass andere sich in ihr schwer zurechtfinden können.
Genau. Und dieser die anderen, darauf hat er auch gerade abgestellt. Es geht nicht darum, eine Realität so aufzuschreiben, dass die anderen endlich einsehen, das ist die Realität. Sondern ein Angebot für Anschlussfähigkeit zu machen, dem gefolgt wird. Und wir sehen das ja heute in Amerika, heute Nacht wurde dieses Big Beautiful Bill. Das ist so groß, über tausend Seiten lang. Keiner weiß, was es real in der materiellen Welt wirklich bedeutet. Man muss jetzt einfach mit Narrativen hier versuchen, resonant und widerständig mit so Sachverhalten umzugehen. In der Hoffnung darauf, dass Geschichten derjenigen, die dann sozusagen die Betroffenen sind, irgendwie in Einklang zu bringen sind mit dem, was im Senat und im Kongress da grad passiert. Und wenn das nicht klappt, und wir müssen das jetzt auch alle ein bisschen abwarten und halt gucken, wer beobachtet wie. Wir sitzen hier in Deutschland, wir werden das die nächsten Monate trotzdem ausführlich diskutieren. Wie geht denn das eigentlich? Und dafür gibt es ein wichtiges Kriterium. Wenn also Realität ausfällt, wenn Listen to the Science einfach nicht funktioniert, weil wir so einen Raffinessebetrieb über den Nebel der Realität legen und dann sagen, ok, hier, erkenne ich so ein bisschen was. Es gibt ein anderes Kriterium, das der Penn hier jetzt herausstellt, dass das maßgebliche ist und wir hören zuerst das Kriterium und dann mache ich mein Urteil schon mal über Robin Alexander.
You have to go down to is this a human heart that I trust? And getting back to the very beginning of our conversation, is this a narrative that is at least one that I can share and make match with what I believe?
So, und jetzt können wir uns ja einfach die Frage stellen. Wir beide haben das Buch schon gelesen und die ganze Besprechung wird gleich eine Argumentation zu meinem Urteil jetzt sein. Ich glaube Robin Alexander kein Wort und ich vertraue ihm nicht, dass er das Gute im Herzen hat oder überhaupt nur ein bisschen mich auch im Blick hat. Das klingt ja zart. Bei den Schreiben dieser Lektüre, sondern ich habe, wie wir alle wissen, kürzlich auch ein zum Teil politisches Sachbuch geschrieben, in dem ich auch zum Teil chronistisch da durchgehe, nur während Robin Alexander einfach 450 Seiten über die letzte Ampel schreibt und ich mir denke, Momentchen mal, wenn man schon irgendwie so anfangen, hier journalistisch und chronistenpflichtig anzufangen, dann können wir doch mal sagen, das steht eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag. Und im Koalitionsvertrag steht drin, das wichtigste zivilpolitische, gesellschaftspolitische Vorhaben ist hier Kindergrundsicherung und solche Sachen. Null Thematisierung. Das, was die Leute am meisten interessiert, am meisten in ihrem Leben sich wirklich niederschlägt. Finanziell einfach die größten Effekte hervorruft. Findet in diesem Buch einfach gar nicht statt, sondern er hat sich ganz selektiv auf seinen Scheiß, und da würde ich jetzt sagen, den halt der Kanzler der Neue so beschäftigt, und er wird dann umjubelt und unterstützt.
Die 100 andere Journalisten und 200 weitere Politiker interessiert. Also das ist eine Perspektive, die zwar aus dem Inneren kommt, aber auch nur für die Inneren eigentlich gedacht ist. Also wir dürfen jetzt so ein bisschen Mäuschen spielen, dürfen mal durchs Schlüsselloch blicken, dürfen erfahren, wer ein bisschen viel trinkt, wenn ein Koalitionsausschuss ist. Solche Dinge bekommen wir auch noch mitgegeben. Aber das bleibt ja alles auf der Boulevard-Ebene. Und diese anderen Fragen, die man stellen könnte, die werden nicht beantwortet, beziehungsweise die werden überhaupt gar nicht aufgetan. Und stattdessen lässt man sich ganz ein auf eine Erzählweise, die man ja selbst produziert hat. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Mann zu tun, der für Springer arbeitet. Der schreibt für die Welt, ist mit der Bild-Zeitung also nah verbunden. Und die Bild-Zeitung als Meinungsmache kommt gar nicht vor. Es ist einfach so, es gibt Ereignisse in der Welt. Zum Beispiel, dass ein Flüchtling mit dem Messer Kinder ermordet. Und dann ist das Ereignis einfach an sich das, was zum Beispiel dann den Kanzler oder künftigen Kanzlerkandidaten emotionalisiert. Wie darüber berichtet wurde, welche Rolle die Medien dabei spielen, welche Rolle Robin Alexander explizit selbst dabei spielt, das kommt in dem Sinne gar nicht vor. Und wir versuchen uns mal einen Eindruck zu vermitteln, wie das hier läuft. Und wenn Alexander sogar an einigen Punkten Recht haben sollte, dann habe ich wirklich Angst. Also für mich ist das Buch, also sollte Robin Alexander wirklich richtig liegen mit dieser Art der Beschreibung, dann sollte man schon mal darüber nachdenken, wo man möglichst schnell hin kann.
Flüchtet. Ja, wartet nicht auf Putin.
Wir hören jetzt mal in den Machtwechsel Podcast, den haben sie live aufgeführt. Alexander, mit Dagmar Rosenfeld. Es geht um die Buchpräsentation. Rosenfeld leitet mal ein.
Wir werden beginnen mit dem Kapitel Blutart. Und ich möchte das einordnen, damit alle wissen, wo wir uns befinden. Wir befinden uns im Januar 2025. Und die Lage in der CDU in den Umfragen ist nicht gut. Es geht für die CDU nach unten. Es erscheint die erste Umfrage bei INSA, die die CDU unter 30 Prozent sieht. Das Attentat auf den Weihnachtsmarkt in Magdeburg ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt gerade mal vier Wochen her. Und in der öffentlichen Debatte dominiert das Thema Asyl und Migration.
Ja, also hier sehen wir schon.
Die öffentliche Debatte ist, wie er in den Medien machen das.
Dieses Buch benutzt, also benutzt, ich würde so sagen, es benutzt uns Leser als Schwungmasse für die Reputation eines Journalisten, der gerne in der kommenden Regierung wieder ein bisschen mehr Zugang hätte als in der letzten. Das wäre jetzt so eine Unterstellung, die man machen kann. Das hört man ja hier schon. Blutbad, also Menschen sterben auf der Straße. Und das Erste, was sie dazu rein assoziiert ist, die Umfrage der CDU sind nicht gut.
Ja, wir hören weiter.
Und dann kommt der 22. Januar in Aschaffenburg attackiert ein 28-jähriger Mann im Park eine Kindergartengruppe mit einem Messer. Er tötet ein Kind sowie einen Erwachsenen. Und wieder ist der Täter ein ausreisepflichtiger Asylbewerber.
Und jetzt?
So, warte, auch hier. Ein Mann sticht auf Kinder ein. Und deswegen Migrationspolitik. Weil wer hätte gedacht, dass man vielleicht erst mal an einen Notarzt denkt oder sowas? Nein, sofort im Innenministerium anruft.
Ja, es ist also es wird die ganze Zeit nur, also erst mal bei dem Weihnachtsmarkt wissen wir ja, das war ja jemand, der 2006 nach Deutschland kam, der hier als Arzt gearbeitet hat, der also bestens integriert war, wenn man so möchte, sich dann radikalisiert hat übers Internet. Wir wissen nicht genau, was sonst noch in diesem Kopfe so vorgegangen ist. Er hat aber auch Posts von der AfD geteilt. Wir haben es nicht mit jemandem zu tun, der klassisch islamistisch unterwegs war, ganz im Gegenteil. Jetzt haben wir es hier mit einem offenbar durchgedrehten zu tun, der möglicherweise, ja, hätte gestoppt werden können, wenn man früher auf dies und das reagiert hätte. Also auf diesen Fall konkret. Und wahrscheinlich gibt es ganz viele Sachen, wo man jetzt in Deutschland sagen kann, da müsste man eigentlich reagieren. Da wurden doch Behörden gewarnt. Warum lässt man den immer noch frei herumlaufen? Leute, die psychotisch sind und im höchsten Maße gewaltbereit. All das ist ja vollkommen richtig. Aber davon abzuleiten, ja, wir brauchen da eine ganz, eine gesamte Migrationspolitik bedeutet ja einfach, einen Generalverdacht auszusprechen. Und interessant ist die, also die, die Erzählung, die ja immer wieder zu zu lesen ist. Wir gehen dann nachher im Salon nochmal genauer drauf ein, ist ja Friedrich Merz ändert seine Migrationspolitik, seinen Wahlkampf. Er will jetzt wird sich Wahlkampf machen zum Thema Migration. Aber es wird so getan, als sei das...
Gegen alle Beraterleistungen, die er vorher erhalten hat.
Ja, und vor allem würde ich auch sagen, es stimmt doch gar nicht, dass dann das große Umschwenken kommt. Ich habe dann mal Perplexity befragt, habe mir Artikel anzeigen lassen. Zum Beispiel gab es schon am 13. Dezember, also noch vor Weihnachtsmarkt und allem, ja, hat man den Parteitag gehabt. Und da steht in der süddeutschen CDU-CSU verlangen eine grundsätzliche Wende in der Migrationspolitik. Wir kontrollieren die deutschen Staatsgrenzen und setzen konsequente Zurückweisungen an der Grenzen durch, heißt es im Entwurf. Ja, es geht darum, der Familiennachzug zu subsidiär Schutzberechtigten soll ausgesetzt werden. Also genau das, was wir jetzt bekommen. Das ist ja gar nicht das Resultat von Magdeburg oder von Aschaffenburg, sondern das hat man doch im Dezember gesagt. Ich habe da nochmal weiter geschaut. Im Oktober sagen Union-Spitzen auch dazu, Friedrich Merz warnen davor, es würden durch Migration No-Go-Areas entstehen für Deutsche. Und da müsse man, und die Ampel sei nicht bereit und im Stande etwas dagegen zu tun, deswegen müsse man wohl Migration den Wahlkampf nicht aufnehmen, obwohl man es eigentlich nicht wolle. Aber wir haben schon monatelang eine Dauer-Migrationsdebatte, die sich dann natürlich nochmal zuspitzt. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die CDU sagt jetzt, ach, da hatten wir nie dran gedacht. Ja, wir hören jetzt Robin Alexander.
Die Strategen in der Union können ihr Glück kaum fassen.
Also man muss sagen, jetzt geht es um dieses Blutbad. Man denkt jetzt, also sieht man auch, wie zynisch ja überall das dann doch gesprochen wird. Also Scholz hält eine Rede und alle denken, okay, von der CDU jetzt verkündet der eine große Migrationswende, dann nimmt er uns das Thema weg. Scholz machte aber eine vage formulierte Rede, die seine Betroffenheit ausdrückt, aber er kündigt jetzt nichts konkret an. Und jetzt wird daraus jetzt gemacht, ja das ist ja toll, jetzt können wir da richtig rein. Und man sieht ja, okay, da stimmt ja irgendwas mit dieser Art der Emotionalisierung, nicht die uns gleich verkauft wird.
Wie schon nach dem Anschlag in Magdeburg lässt Olaf Scholz erneut eine riesige kommunikative Lücke, analysieren sie. Diese Lücke kann Friedrich Merz füllen. Ja, er muss sogar. Andernfalls wird es Alice Weidel mit ihren radikalen AfD-Parolen tun.
Die hat er jetzt sonst geschwiegen, wie wir wissen. Die hat sich ja ganz zurückgehalten deshalb.
Sieht der Kanzlerkandidat das auch so? Oder bleibt er bei seinem bisherigen vorsichtigen Kurs?
Habt ihr, hat irgendjemand bei Friedrich Merz im puncto Migration in den letzten, sagen wir, zwölf Monaten einen vorsichtigen Kurs erlebt? Also, wovon reden wir denn hier?
Um 22 Uhr lädt Merz zu einer Videokonferenz.
So, bei dieser Videokonferenz ist dann auch wer anwesend?
Linnemann im Teil, Frey und Dobrindt, außerdem Joachim Herrmann, der bayerische Innenminister, der über den Ermittlungsstand der dortigen Behörden informieren soll, sowie Andrea Lindholz, stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende und eine der wenigen Frauen in März Berliner Führungsteam. Zugeschaltet ist Lindholz an diesem Abend, aber aus einem anderen Grund. Aschaffenburg ist ihr Wahlkreis. Sie war in der Stadt, als der Anschlag passierte. In ihrem Wahlkreisbüro hörte sie die Rotoren des Rettungshubschraubers und erlebte anschließend, welche Ängste die Stadtbevölkerung ausstand.
Also sie hörte einen Rettungshubschrauber. Das ist ihre Nähe zu dem Ereignis. Es ist hier Landkreis. Und jetzt schildert sie ein bisschen die Situation in der Stadt.
Der Täter konnte zunächst fliehen. Es gab Gerüchte, dass mehrere Männer mit Messern unterwegs seien. Lindholz sprach mit Angehörigen der Opfer, mit Polizisten, die zum Tatort geeilt waren. In der Runde mit Friedrich Merz schildert Andrea Lindholz ihre Erlebnisse sehr detailliert und sehr eindringlich. Wie die Erzieherinnen versucht haben, den Bollerwagen mit den Kindern vom Täter wegzuziehen. Wie der Täter sie aber weiter verfolgt und dann mit einem Küchenmesser auf den kleinen, zweijährigen Jungen eingestrochen habe. Wie der Täter extra noch die Mütze und den Schal des Jungen abgenommen habe, um ihnen den Hals stechen zu können. Insgesamt siebenmal. Wie eine 59-jährige Erzieherin beim Versuch, sich vor das Kind zu werben.
Und so weiter. Also was wir jetzt hier präsentiert bekommen, ist diese Rede, die ja absolut verständlich ist. Lindholz schildert das dann da und natürlich ist man dabei emotional. Jetzt müssen wir aber natürlich aus der politischen Perspektive draufblicken und sagen, ja, ich kann das mir jetzt ganz im Detail nochmal anhören, aber ich habe auch ein Vorstellungsvermögen, wie grauenhaft so was ist, wenn auf Kinder eingestochen wird und so weiter. Ja, das ist ja völlig klar. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, wohin führt mich diese Erzählung? Also wenn ich jetzt das gehört habe, sage ich dann dazu, Migrationspolitik. Also ist das meine Antwort. Wir springen mal zu dem nächsten Clip. Merz reagiert.
Merz reagiert sehr emotional auf ihre Schilderungen. Mehrere Teilnehmer der Videorunde werden hinterher berichten, dass Friedrich Merz tief bewegt, ja regelrecht erschüttert gewesen sei. Zeitweise stockt ihm die Stimme, das Kinderziel der Attacke waren, setzt ihm besonders zu. Seine Bestürzung darüber äußert er wieder und wieder. Merz erinnert in seinen Worten auch an Magdeburg, an das viele Blut, das er dort auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gesehen hat.
Wir erinnern uns nochmal gerade Magdeburg, war nicht die Frage von, da ist jetzt ein Flüchtling vor zwei Jahren gekommen, den hat man da im Heim vergessen. Aber er verknüpft das schon beides.
Die herumliegende Puppe, das alles könne nicht so weitergehen, sagt Merz.
Das ist jetzt also der Schritt, der bedeutet, ich habe jetzt meine Erinnerungen an ein Blutband, ich habe noch mal Erinnerungen gehört an ein Blutband, und die führen mich jetzt zu einer Migrationspolitik. Wir könnten ja auch jetzt sagen, ich will nicht diese Attentate relativieren, aber es gibt ja auch andere schreckliche Taten, die zum Beispiel mit häuslicher Gewalt zu tun haben, die von Deutschen ausgeübt werden und so weiter. Und die kann ich mindestens genauso emotional erzählen. Und davon kann ich Dinge ableiten, wie wir brauchen 1000 Frauenhäuser mehr, wir brauchen dies und das. Wir haben diese ganzen Armutsberichte jetzt bekommen, die einen fassungslos machen. Auch da kann ich aus einer Emotionalisierung heraus große Politik ableiten. Passiert hier aber nicht, passiert nur bei diesem Thema. Und ich finde wirklich interessant, wie jetzt hier damit umgegangen wird. Denn wir haben es ja jetzt mit dem künftigen Kanzler zu tun, der aus der Emotion heraus und mit seinen Strategen Linnemann, Spahn im Hintergrund, jetzt so agiert.
Asylbewerber als tickende Zeitbomben. Das hatte Merz also schon gehört, bevor Andrea Lindholz ihre Erlebnisse in Aschaffenburg so emotional schilderte.
Denn er hatte zuvor schon mit dem Chef der Bundespolizei gesprochen.
Seine Gedanken und Gefühle fasst Merz an diesem Abend so zusammen. Es reicht. Auch im Herrmann, der bayerische Innenminister, bestärkt ihn in dieser Einschätzung. Die Innenminister aller Bundesländer.
Also wenn man jetzt das ja mal ernst nehmen würde, es reicht. Also er will, dass solche Taten nicht mehr passieren. Und dann müsste man sich ja genau fragen, was wäre zu tun. Also das radikalste Programm ist ja dann, dass der AfD zu sagen, Remigration, wenn keiner mehr da ist, kann keiner mehr was tun. So.
Ja, dann wird halt nichts mehr getan.
Dann wird auch nichts mehr sonst. So, dann ist so. Und er fängt jetzt an mit irgendeinem Punkteplan.
Da auch die Sozialdemokraten unter ihnen seien überzeugt davon, dass es so nicht weitergehen könne. Anschließend tragen Dobrindt, Frey und Linnemann vor, worüber sie am Nachmittag mit Spahn beraten haben, einen Aufschlag für eine neue, viel härtere Migrationspolitik.
Und die wird dann umgesetzt und wir werden nachher dann darüber reden, diese Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD und alles, was dann da so kommt. Und da merken wir, da wird im Blindflug regiert, entschieden und sonst was aus einer hohen Emotionalisierung heraus. Also sollte Robin Alexander auch nur ein bisschen damit recht haben, was er da beschreibt und ja, er ist ja tief drin in den Sachen und die Fakten, die hier in dem Buch stehen, die werden schon an sich stimmen. Wir beklagen die Auswahl, die Perspektive und so weiter. Da muss ich ja sagen, rette sich wer kann, wenn da mal irgendwie eine Bedrohung für die NATO sich möglicherweise einstellen könnte oder irgendwas noch mal emotionalisierend ist für Friedrich Merz, was Putin getan hat oder so, dass man einfach sagt, so wir ziehen ins Manöver, ist uns jetzt alles egal. Ich habe Emotionen, ich habe kleine Kinder gesehen. Also das ist doch unglaublich, wenn das stimmen sollte, dass das in dieser Weise ist, dann muss man sich ja wirklich fürchten vor der Politik.
Also ich habe ja schon immer gesagt, keine Angst vor Verschöungstheorien. Weshalb ich jetzt mal von der ganz großen anderen Richtung, ich frage mich, wann, und wir haben jetzt schon in Amerika die erste Meldung, ein Quartal minus 0,5 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum, also Wirtschaftsschrumpfung sozusagen, obwohl ja noch dieses Ganze, wir machen die Lager voll wegen Zollandrohungen mit reinfällt. Also wir sind eigentlich bei minus drei, vier Prozent. So das zweite Quartal wird gerade ausgerechnet. Heute haben wir Big Beautiful Bill. Also gigantische Diss-Funktionalitäten bei der Reichtumsverteilung. Ich frage mich, wer soll überhaupt noch in Amerika, was arbeiten? So Bildungssystem wird zerschlagen. Ausländer werden rausgeschickt. Wie soll das funktionieren? Ja und irgendwie frage ich mich die ganze Zeit, wann kommt der erste Text und die Akkumentation muss gar nicht aufwendig sein, um wahnsinnig überzeugend zu sein, der einfach zeigt, wir haben ein Dokument gefunden. Maga war eine Idee von Chi 2015, mit Amtseinführung. Das ist unser Projekt.
Ich glaube ja immer an die interne Blödheit.
Die kommt ja dazu, die wurde ja ausgebeutet. In Amerika erleben wir gerade extrem impulskontrollgestörte Politik. Reiche Leute sagen, sie wären gern reicher, zack, erledigt. Ärmer Leute können sich nicht wehren, aussortiert. Ausländer, sichtbar auf der Straße, wegsortieren. Also es wird alles genau auf den ersten Blick so. Was ist mein erster Gedanke, den ich habe? Das mache ich. Und ich habe letztens in Deutschland vom Körsaal einen wahnsinnig interessanten Vortrag gehört, den ich jetzt natürlich auch nur aus dem Geiste kurz zusammenfasse, wo darüber gesprochen wurde, wie im Gehirn so kleine Hemmer Gedanken in die Länge ziehen. Also ein Impuls sozusagen, ne, das wird jetzt noch nicht zu Ende rationalisiert, hier kommt jetzt so ein Hemmer rein. Und diese Hemmer, also dieses Verzögern, werden dann auch nochmal ganz clever gehemmt, sodass überhaupt eine Idee von, wir sind keine Hunde, die man innerhalb von drei Sekunden das Leckerli geben muss, damit sie noch verbinden können, ah ja, weil ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben bin, kriege ich das Leckerli, sondern ne, wir kriegen so ein Bildungssystem gespannt. Wir machen dir heute ein Versprechen, bauen das dann aus, mit so einer sloterdeutschen Philosophie, der Vorfreude auf dich selbst, nennen es Bildung und in fünf Jahren kriegst du einen Abschluss, der dir die nächsten 50 Jahre mehr Einkommen beschert, so ja. So, das sind zivilisatorische Errungenschaften. In dieser Politik, die wir hier gerade dokumentiert bekommen, wird uns einfach erklärt, es ist ganz normal, dass unser Kanzler einfach so ein Dreisekunden Hund ist. Wenn wir das in anderen Politikfeldern hätten, Familienpolitik, wenn wir die Familienpolitik so unterdampfen würden, wie die Migrationspolitik gerade abläuft, dann würde das bedeuten, das wäre feuerfrei. Männer würden über die Straße gehen, sagen, die Schnikse finde ich geil, da ist ein Gebüsch. Das wäre die Familienpolitik von Friedrich Merz. So, Punkt. Und das auf 450 Seiten auszubreiten mit so einem Nimbus, also wenn ihr nicht wirklich jeden Satz davon gelesen habt und alle Details kennt, die ich euch hier schildere, dann dürft ihr nicht mitreden.
Und dieses Prinzip wird ja jetzt nicht nur darauf angewandt, sondern wir sehen das ja dann auch, wenn es um NATO, Außenpolitik und so weiter geht. Wir ahnen schon, es gibt dann ein Video, das Friedrich Merz sieht und das soll angeblich alles bei ihm umwerfen. Und dieses Video ist natürlich Selenski im Obel Office. Das wirft alles um und wie gesagt, wir gehen das jetzt gleich durch. Ich würde sagen, man muss wirklich, ich habe schon mal geguckt, wie das, ich donne mal, kundlich mit der Schweiz. Die sind ja geruhsamer. Also der Schweiz, sagt man manchmal, ist ein bisschen langsam, aber es ist geruhsamer.
Genau, wenn man in der Schweiz fragt, wer regiert hier gerade, nenn mir Namen. Niemand weiß welche, niemand.
Die Schweizer schon. Aber die sagen ja, da müssen wir noch mal drüber nachdenken. Und das, glaube ich, ist genau die richtige Haltung. Ich bin ja nicht jemand, der ein Scholz-Fan ist oder so, aber mir ist über die Lektüre dieses Buches Scholz sehr sympathisch geworden. Auch wenn der Autor das überhaupt nicht beabsichtigt, war für mich jetzt noch mal so klar, dass Scholz sich genau aus diesem pafflowschen Reizreaktionsschema hinaus manövrieren wollte. Das gelang ihm am Ende nicht, aber dass er zumindest diesen Versuch noch mal unternommen hat. Aus dieser affektgetriebenen, medialen Blase auszusteigen und auch aus der politischen Blase, die so affektgetrieben ist und zu sagen, ich mach das jetzt doch noch mal anders, finde ich bemerkenswert. Ich glaube, das wird man irgendwann später noch mal so resümieren können. Man kann es aber auch dann zwischen den Zeilen bei Robin Alexander lesen. Wir werden im Salon auch einen Clip von Friedrich Merz spielen in Bezug auf die AfD, nämlich er hat sich da beim Parteitag ja mal dazu geäußert, warum er mit der AfD nicht zusammenarbeiten will. Und weil dieses Buch ja Letzte Chance heißt, so als sei jetzt Friedrich Merz die letzte Chance für die Mitte und die AfD zu verhindern und so was, würde ich mal gerne fragen, ob die Brandmauer nicht schon eingerissen ist. Und zwar in einer anderen Weise, als wir jetzt darüber nachdenken. Ja, es gab diese Zusammenarbeit und die Migrationspolitik, da sind die ja fast deckungsgleich bei vielen Fragen. Aber ich würde es auch noch mal anders mit einem Clip zeigen wollen. Wir gehen also da ganz tief rein. Ich habe auch, ich kündige das hier schon an, kritische Anmerkungen noch mal zur Linkspartei. Da erfahren wir nämlich bei Robin Alexander noch mal ein sehr wichtiges Detail. Also ich finde manche Details sehr gut, die er hier zutage fördert oder die ich sehe aufschlussreich. Man muss ja nicht die große Erzählung von Robin Alexander unterstützen, aber die Sachen, die er da manchmal anbietet, sind sehr gut. Und sonst habe ich mal schöne Sachen mitgebracht. Also wirklich interessante Sachen. Ich habe es schon angesprochen, diese Poetik-Vorlesung, die heißt Stehlen, Schimpfen, Spielen, als Countdown gestaltet. Jeder wird es kennen, wenn man einen Abgabetermin hat und will eigentlich nicht und kann nicht und so. Und die Autoren haben dasselbe Problem. Wir lernen sehr viel über das Schreiben allgemein und über die Welt. Johann S. Guse hat…
Den kenne ich, der war bei der FAZ als Hospitant zu meiner Zeit.
Ach, siehst du. Und der ist ja nicht nur ein Romanschriftsteller, sondern auch einer, der sich hineinwagt in etwas, was man ja Großreportage nennen kann, aber es hat auch wieder was Romanhaftes. Das Buch heißt 1000 Mal so viel Geld wie jetzt. Und er hat sich mit Männern getroffen, die durch Krypto reich geworden sind. Es sind aber nicht die Männer, die man so kennt in Dubai oder auch Superjachten, sondern er spricht mit den Sleepern, mit denen, die immer noch in der Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung leben, aber einfach unfassbar viel Geld plötzlich haben. Ganz interessant ist auch auf so einer Krypto-Konferenz, der Regisseur Dominik Graf hat ein Buch geschrieben über Schauspielerei im Film.
Das ist dein Vorwortgeber für dein Film?
Genau, das ist der Vorwortgeber für mein Filmanalysebuch. In der Tat hat Nina Scholz über die indischen Studenten geschrieben, die in Berlin Lieferfahrten machen mit dem Fahrrad. Und in welcher Situation die eigentlich sind und was die so blechen müssen, ist es wirklich wieder der ganze Wahnsinn.
Da könnte man emotional werden.
Da könnte man emotional werden. Da könnte man wirklich sagen, jetzt muss hier sich was ändern, jetzt reicht's. Aber das tut es natürlich nicht. Und ich werde noch ein Quartett vorstellen. Streichquartett ist ja meine Lieblingsformation. Mendelssohn und Dvorak.
Sehr gut. Ich bin heute sehr eng fokussiert auf KI-Themen. Kommentare herzlich willkommen. Sam Altman hat über The Gentle Singularity geschrieben. Also die begrusamte herkommende Singularität. Wir wollen das einfach mal dokumentieren, wie hier die Wortwahl ist. Denn vielleicht, wenn es anders kommt, könnten wir ihn noch mal dran erinnern, wie wir von ihm belogen wurden. Die New York Times da heute ist ja gerade eine sehr interessante Zeit. Also dieses Big Beautiful Bill ist jetzt da. Das heißt, Elon Musk ist ausreichend sauer, will jetzt diese Make-up-Party gründen. Und in wenigen Tagen endet ja auch dieser Zollaufschub von Trump. Also das ist ja jetzt auch so eine Pokersituation. Jetzt muss Karten gezeigt werden. Und in den New York Times hat Frank Bruni, der dort ohnehin viel Meinungsredaktion macht, mit Christen, Soltes, Anderson und Nate Silver gesprochen. Nate Silver kennen wir. Der macht ja viel mit Zahlen. Und die Anderson auch, aber halt für die republikanische Meinungsforschung. Also ein Streitgespräch zur Frage, ist Trump jetzt eigentlich unter Wasser? Und wie sehen die jetzt anstehenden Wahlkämpfe, begonnen auch jetzt mit New York im November und so aus? Und dann die beiden Texte. Your Brain on Chat GPT. Also diese MIT-Forschung zur Frage, was läuft jetzt in unserem Gehirn wirklich ab, wenn wir GPT nutzen, in einem ganz spezifischen Anwendungsfall, den ich wahnsinnig interessant finde, denn es ist einer der hauptsächlichen meiner und grundsätzlich, wie es gerade benutzt wird. Und dann Apples Illusion of Thinking, was die jetzt in ihrer Forschung, welche Fragestellungen die hatten, welche Probleme die sehen. Und wir können nur spekulieren, in welchem Rahmen Apple selbst hier Interesse hat, die Technik so ein bisschen Wind aus der Segel zu nehmen und so. Aber ja, ganz interessant. Das müssen wir auch. Also ich dokumentiere halt im Grunde, was hier gerade Sprech ist.
Sehr gut. Wir sprechen also darüber gleich im Salon. Beginnen mit Letzte Chance, der neue Kanzler und der Kampf um die Demokratie von Robin Alexander und fragen uns, ob Friedrich Merz wirklich die letzte Chance ist oder eher schon die Brücke hin zur AfD. Wie gesagt, wir werden da noch einen Clip hören und auch über den Journalismus, die Medien noch mal diskutieren, auch noch mal vielleicht an manche Dinge anknüpfen, die wir schon in Bezug auf Harald Wälzer und Richard David Precht uns deutlich gemacht haben. Das ist wirklich aufschlussreich, noch mal in dieses Buch reinzugehen, denn so ein Buch, das uns so ärgert, ist natürlich ideal eigentlich als Grundlage. Wer das alles hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun. Nämlich kann man den Salon abonnieren. Das geht über Steady, über Apple und Patreon. Man geht einfach auf die Neue Zwanziger Seite, neuezwanziger.de, dort ist ein goldener Button, da kommt man zu Steady. Das ist auch das von uns Präferierte. Da ist wirklich der Zugang zu allem, was wir jemals aufgenommen haben. Bei den anderen fehlen ja so die Anfangsmonate ein bisschen. Da kann man jedenfalls ein Abo abschließen mit 3 Euro. Im Monat ist man dabei und kann dann auch Zugang haben zu allen alten Folgen, auch zu den Live-Salons. Man kann auch dort dann, wenn man möchte, den Salon verschenken. Und außerdem, wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann natürlich auch darüber das bequem hören. Manche wollen aber auch den Apple Cosmos aus verständlichen Gründen nicht verlassen, weil es einfach einfach ist. Da kostet es dann ein bisschen mehr, weil Apple eine größere Gebühr abverlangt. Aber auch da mit einem Klick ist man dabei und kann dann Zugang zum Salon haben.
Genau, die Versorgung ist auch dort gesichert.
Ich will noch gerade auf den Termin im August hin, an 23. August, sind wir in Bornheim, hier in Frankfurt also direkt und werden dort unseren Sommersalon veranstalten. Karten bekommt man einfach über den Link. Da kann man sich im Saalplan etwas buchen. Man kann von allen Plätzen gut die Bühne sehen. Es ist also nicht so, dass man da irgendwie dann verdeckt ist und nur die Hälfte mitbekommt oder so. Der Saal ist klimatisiert und wir sind dann auch früh da. Man kann uns auch davor und danach natürliche Ansprüche machen. Ich will noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich am 7.7. in Trier bin, um über Politik und Oper zu sprechen. Am 10.7. spreche ich in Köln über den Diskurs um die Kriegstüchtigkeit. Am 11.7. bin ich in Ludwigshafen, um über die kleinen Holzdiebe und den Kapitalismus zu sprechen.
Sehr gut. Und heute bist du in der Oper.
Ja.
Ich kann heute leider nicht, aber ich habe sie deswegen schon gesehen.
Ja, Alcina von Händel.
Alcina. Es ist spektakulär. Also ich will jetzt grundsätzlich sagen, diese Oper, wenn die im Spielplan auftaucht hier in Frankfurt, muss man sie sehen.
Oder sonst wo, denn es ist wirklich eine der besten Händel.
Ja, da hört man sie dann zumindest und kriegt sie wahrscheinlich auch bestens präsentiert. Aber hier in Frankfurt, Setting 10 von 10 Sterne und natürlich Monika. Abwechselnd in Hotpens und ausladenden Kleidern. Hinter mir saß ein älterer Herr, der meinte, er hätte jetzt schon sieben Alcinas gesehen und so albern wie heute war es ja noch nie.
Und meinte er das positiv oder negativ?
Ich hab dann auch darüber nachgedacht, weil ich in diesem Moment erst dachte, ach so, die meinen das albern. Aber es traf so sehr meinen Geschmack, dass ich das erst gar nicht. Und dann hab ich gedacht, ach ja, okay, ist das albern gemeint, okay, gut. Also es ist wirklich ganz, ganz hervorragend. Ist auch eine, bei der ich jetzt sage, wenn die dann im Spielplein wieder auftaucht, sind meine Töchter fällig. Das muss man gesehen und gehört haben. Also da bin ich ein bisschen neidisch, dass so. Sie wird ja nur noch heute und Sonntag nochmal gespielt.
Aber auch sonst kann man Alchina oder andere Händel-Operen natürlich überall erleben. Jetzt nicht laufend, aber sie werden doch viel gespielt. Die, das Barock-Revival dauert ja Gott sei Dank an und immer werden diese Opern gegeben. Insofern ist da Frankfurt nicht der einzige Ort dafür.
Außerdem, ich erwünsche mir Hinweise, denn ich war bei meiner ersten Städelausstellungseröffnung. Werner Tübke wurde ausgestellt, Zeichnung gemacht. Ein wohl sehr zurückhaltender Künstler, der viel gezeichnet, aber dann auch mit Farbe gearbeitet hat. Und es war eine Privatsammlung von Eduard Boucan, der auf der Bühne mit war, um die Einführung zu machen. Man hat sich dagegen entschieden, einen Vortrag zu halten bei 36 Grad. Oder ob das mit dem Wetter zu tun hat, weiß ich nicht. Es fand wohl für die Leute dort ungewöhnlich ein Dialog statt. Für mich, okay, das war die erste Veranstaltung. Und er hat ja damals unter Joachim Fest im Vöetor geschrieben. Und war dann gleichzeitig noch so dieser Kunst zugewandt, dass er da selber diese Sammlung aufgebaut hat und so. Und es war ein so überraschender Einblick, kann man gar nicht eintauchen, in dieses alte Vöetor-Leben, als die Welt noch richtig funktioniert hat. Und noch Platz war nach vier Seiten Politik und drei davon langweilig, sich dem Vöetor hinzugeben und nicht alle die ganze Zeit hier, ist es jetzt die letzte Chance und so. Also das war sehr gut. Wenn so was häufiger stattfindet, würde ich da gern häufiger hingehen. Und es scheint ja wohl häufiger stattzufinden.
Also du möchtest jetzt die Kranken des Vöetor verbunden mit der Kunst erleben.
Ich möchte grundsätzlich sehen, was in diesen Museen los ist. Und ich habe festgestellt, in so einer Ausstellung geht man mit ganz anderen Augen, wenn man vorher einfach eine Stunde, also in der Oper blenden wir die Einführungsveranstaltungen immer so ein bisschen aus, weil die Oper ist das Erlebnis. Das ist natürlich bei Ausstellungen so ein bisschen anders.
Ja, man kann es so oder so machen. Also es kommt drauf an. Ich habe natürlich auch schon schreckliche Ausstellungseröffnungen erlebt oder sehr gute Operneinführungen. Also das wechselt. Aber ich würde dann sagen, du musst dann auch manchmal Frankfurt verlassen. Du musst dann aufbrechen, denn Deutschland hat ja ganz wunderbare Museen. Auch die kleineren Städte, ob das in Brühl das Max-Ernz-Museum ist oder das Burda-Museum in Baden-Baden, was auch immer.
Wäre ich auch bereit, das zu tipsen, das kenne ich.
In Schwäbisch-Hall ist der Wirt, hat ja da seine große Sammlung auch. Das ist interessant. Es gibt viele Orte. Jetzt gehen wir aber erstmal in den Salon, werden also jetzt über viel Politik diskutieren und ob wir wirklich an dem Punkt sind, wo wir sagen, ja Friedrich Merz ist unsere letzte Chance.
Zum Glück rettet er uns.
Er rettet uns vielleicht sogar. Skepsis ist angesagt und wir müssen ja mit dem Journalismus hart ins Gericht gehen. Das jetzt alles gleich im Salon. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert.